hacer de áfrica una prioridad política
para francia el recién reelegido y
manuel marco muestra su ambición con
esta primera gira por el continente y
una primera parada en camerún el tema
central de los intercambios con su
homólogo volvía siendo la crisis
alimentaria que amenaza a áfrica varios
países del continente dependen en gran
medida de las importaciones agrícolas
sobre todo del trigo ucraniano y ruso
los alimentos y la energía- se han
convertido en armas de guerra rusas esto
nos pone a todos frente a nuestras
responsabilidades debemos ayudar al
continente africano a producir más para
sí misma no estás fulminan el pasado mes
de marzo la unión europea y la unión
africana pusieron en marcha iniciativas
para aumentar la producción agrícola en
el continente y francia tiene previsto
apoyar otros proyectos en camerún tanto
al contexto social cuando vemos el
contexto sociopolítico actual con la
hostilidad de francia en malí la guerra
en ucrania es algo muy bueno francia
llega a camerún para calentar sus
relaciones y reforzar su apoyo
grafos es eso por otro lado en un
momento en que francia está perdiendo
influencia en su antiguo dominio a favor
de china y rúsia parís quiere asegurarse
la fidelidad del socio camerunés se
esperan las declaraciones de mayor marco
en materia de seguridad ya que el
noroeste y suroeste del país están
plagados desde hace cinco años de
enfrentamientos entre grupos armados
separatistas y las fuerzas del orden en
estas regiones se acusa a las
autoridades camerunesas de violaciones
de los derechos humanos y no sería bueno
que el presidente macrón viniera aquí y
no pusiera sobre la mesa con su homólogo
los temas de derechos humanos que son
muy respetados en francia esta persona
mudó a continuación en mayor makro se
desplazará a benin guinea bisseau donde
de nuevo se tratara de la seguridad
alimentaria y regional